so the united states government spent
nearly 90 billion dollars training the
afghan army and yet that army collapsed
almost immediately how did that happen
well a 2009 report from the guardian
suggests one possible contributing
factor many afghan soldiers were high on
the job
you don't have a helmet on having
doesn't have a rifle right now how is he
ready it's like having 26 kids that i
have to watch after
it really is ready would be on the road
staged ready to move at 8 30.
i think if they introduced drug testing
to the afghan army uh we would lose
probably three quarters to
maybe 80 85 percent of the army it
requires telling them almost 30 times
don't do this don't do this don't do
this don't do this don't do this come on
let's go
so that video is deeply offensive to
people in washington who have to cover
up the waste
that they have perpetrated in our name
over 20 years but it's real
american soldiers in many cases had to
teach afghan recruits how to read and
write and operate basic equipment
according to nbc news 90
of those who enlisted were illiterate
that's worse than the national rate of
literacy fox's steve harrigan recounted
how ineffective our literacy training
was today watch
i remember going to a graduation
training class of afghan soldiers and
they all spun their diplomas around
because they didn't know which letters
were up
none of them could read after graduation
anyone who's been around afghan national
government soldiers know that you have
to do a mission before payday because
when payday comes
they all disappear
so this went on for 20 years and for
some reason most people didn't notice
michael tracy is an independent
journalist who writes on sub-stack he
just interviewed an afghan veteran last
month who called our entire presence in
the country quote a big money funneling
operation he joins us tonight
thanks so much for coming on michael
tracy so it's it sounds like for those
of us who are scratching our heads and
asking you know why did we keep doing
something that wasn't working maybe
money is part of the answer
well the veteran that i interviewed and
who was a member of the joint command
that oversaw this supposed train and
equip mission
that was exactly his theory he saw that
these defense contracting behemoths
which took as proprietary information
the data that was supposed to be
provided to the american public as to
the status
of those training equipments of the
afghan security forces that data was
essentially concealed from him as a
military officer who was charged with
following that process day-to-day and so
it was a systemic graft and corruption
at the very heart
of the intervention and the reason why i
think as as you seem to speculate
earlier in the show that we see such
this
strange outburst of indignation is
because there are so many people in the
media
in the political class and across the
entire system of essentially american
governmental process
that benefited personally financially
reputationally from what in essence was
a failed
intervention and there are plenty of
guys who are on the front lines who saw
it firsthand who will attest to the
reality of that failure even if they're
the generals
and the national security advisors and
the people who sit on corporate boards
now and pontificate on tv
even if they have a very inter different
interpretation this was an epic colossal
failure and
frankly it's
incumbent on the entire bipartisan
political class which
facilitated this nightmare to to reflect
and so to fixate needlessly
on the logistical details of the
withdrawal it's legitimate you know that
it's open to criticism just like
anything a president does but but i
think that shouldn't distract from a
thorough going
self-criticism as to how we even got
here in the first place over 20 years
under presidents of both parties
i i read yesterday the total coverage on
the network nightly news of afghanistan
for the past five years was like
essentially zero i mean prostate health
got 10 times as much coverage as the
occupation of afghanistan do you do you
have any hope that we will get a clear
accounting of like what we've been doing
there for decades
oh yeah i'm sure all the operatives on
tv
these past few days who are
posturing as though they're these
pure-hearted humanitarians who are so
deeply concerned about afghan women and
girls i'm sure they'll be leading the
charge for this after action report on
how the american global hegemony
suffered this blow i mean i would
definitely trust them in their judgment
to oversee that process no i mean this
this so much of the narrative in the
media as regards this withdrawal is is a
total joke and it's self-absolving
for the people who had a direct role
in enabling such a systemic failure
self-absolving that is a great way to
put it and absolutely true michael tracy
thank you very much
thanks
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else